I'm too cheap to buy a separate
recording programs I just have two
versions of OBS up if there's one thing
everyone in the world can agree on what
is it can the kids are flipping stupid
that's right kids stumped me because
you're a kid and watching this right now
we're calling you why oh that's a poor
little kids this is that's right Kate Oh
what are you gonna do fight it you're
weak but I have kids I feel bad
oh well you know what you should do
those kids can fight them send them to
the ranch that's where all Kate's below
well well well alright since you have
kids Ken we're gonna have to study kids
are getting stupid so you know what not
to do for your kids a childhood but
their allowance because he wasn't happy
with the amount his mom walked out of
her room and saw this what would you do
if this was your child Gabe you send
them to the race send that child to the
ranch instantaneously okay we have Jade
saying keep it and give him a piece of
it any time he asks for money and lame
out well I guess that works too huh not
as satisfying as the ranch right fine
that's the only answer I feel like dr.
Phil anybody just talks back to me ranch
what is that one thing you do as a child
that still gets brought up to this day
yeah do you have anything that you still
get brought up oh oh yeah when I was a
kid I used to I used to sleepwalk
because I was I was so freaking stupid
and Peter up he don't try to walk to the
ranch I tried to walk his ranch but
instead I peed all over my my NES just
peed all over it I just like well I got
into the bathroom and Nintendo's not a
bathroom stupid and I woke up later in
bed all tucked into my pants like
mopping up or you peed on your gaming
console I did Pete oh and you were
sleepwalking mm-hmm when I was like six
years old
she always gets brought up though like
me buddy you're a kid you peed all over
yeah Tendo cuz that's weird what the
hell how dare you not wait wait first of
all do you sleep naked how do you just
pull down your pants and while you're
sleeping you know things happen I just
wanted to play her I want to play some
Mario and I got confused beat everywhere
when my brother was like nine he said
get them ah get the food good I don't
know what that possibly could mean
instead of get the flag on roblox so
they banned him and he cried so hard he
threw up on the carpet understand you
know the pain the pain of forgetting the
El it happens to me as well but the pain
of getting banned on roblox you know
this too well as well did you throw up
on the carpet I did mmm you know what
that means don't you
no rage no have we talked about that my
favorite part about the ranch and on the
show is only like three people have ever
gone to the ranch but it's not no one
ever goes it's such a great joke
election last go to Lake to the water
we're looking for a five-year-old boy
and blue shorts main titties
I mean tightest little boy standing next
to me in blue shorts
hey my name's what a weird coincidence
amazing stupid I see your kids will
watch this video when they grow up I'm
like oh no this is what he thinks about
me
oh you think my kids are gonna watch
people have idios I'll send it to them
now
howdy I got a confession to make yeah
alright my middle name my name is
actually cinnamon t series kin the
teachers have seen four times I'm sorry
[Music]
now Phoenix daughter didn't want
sunscreen so I put her outside and
yelled son get her see this is why I
actually look forward to have kids just
to terrorize guy you go that your kids
are gonna turn out to be like your kids
are really gonna go the ranch no this is
why my kids won't have to go into this
ranch because they'll be educated
freaking terrifying but every chance you
get yeah yeah kids a new level a series
sit down and let's play amnesia together
they're like five years old
get him this is it or the ranch right
now scream louder let me zoom the camera
into your face I'd good job yeah well my
sis brags Thanksgiving about her PhD in
quantitative microbiology I'm gonna be
thinking about this time we took a bath
together whoo that's all I want to think
about I was too and she was five I'm
pooping the tub and she played with it
because boy wait oh so smart then are
you well well well mrs. PhD quantity but
why don't you play with this
microbiology oh that's gross but it's
weird I heard a similar story when I was
a kid like someone played with their own
poop in the bathtub but I'm like what is
this oh yeah poops in the bath day you
you heard the story right yeah you heard
it is that moving on next meme dumb ass
kid almost two-year-old for sale been
crying for 10 minutes cuz she can't get
in the oven with the cornbread
[Music]
[Laughter]
just imagine the kids two nuts of the
oven why can't I be with the cornbread I
told you right when my when my dad found
I think I told you I'm broken
okay well so when I was little older
than eight I you know back in the day
when you went in you didn't understand
how like it's okay Felix he can just
tell me you don't have to I'm trying to
give content today when you went to
adult websites you didn't really
understand how the parents knew that you
went to the website at least I just knew
that my dad could figure it out huh but
I didn't know how so I thought okay if I
go I need to make the motor side of this
so how can I make you know I crossed
this border how do I make the most out
of it and he just just went in all the
way no I I decided hey I'm gonna print
out I'm gonna print out all these
pictures right you're right have I not
told you this I don't think you have
either you ever I forgot about well we
had a really fancy printer that was like
in the cub or and it was a Wi-Fi printer
so it it it as I was printing I realized
no god what have I done this is terrible
so I canceled all the prints and then a
few days later my dad comes in with a
bunch of printed on pictures
yeah and he told me wow you like girls
with big titties and I just grabbed the
pictures and I locked myself in the room
finally dad Thanks I've been waiting for
these - see this is the a prime example
of kick not all kids okay clearly I was
an innovator I was taking that extra
step you know what maybe I need to go to
range maybe that's why I turned out this
way because I never went to the ranch I
[Music]
would say that I've never heard of you
might willingly go to the ranch before I
realize it's time you know that's what
childhoods go to die right yeah that's
where I go to die now tea services
probably passed me anyway I might as
well thank you Ken this has been very
cool but it's time for me to go smash
like and subscribe I'm going through the
ranch man don't go don't go I'm going
and there's nothing you can do to stop
don't go I'm going to the range Abby did
videos so I can you don't see my
subscribers you know where I don't go is
he going all right I'm taking over baby
my chance
who knows that meets after your best
time I've ever had in my life you gotta
try it out can really Wow well I'll go
right now then okay all right see you
later what - BRR simulators becoming
relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor Eagles please do
something yes this game is still
relevant
dear me